Хочеш легально займатися спортом
у закритих під час карантину парках -
приходь до "Київзеленбуду",
жартує озеленювач Михайло Ливаренко.
Ось його замінник спортивним снарядам -
бензокосарка вагою 6 кілограмів.
Робимо рухи по колу і розробляємо талію,
щоб в нас була осина талія.
Якщо без жартів, то у Михайла Ливоренка
та його колег
під час карантину побільшало роботи.
Підприємство хоче підготувати зелені зони
для відпочинку киян
після завершення карантину.
Проте робочих рук катастрофічно не вистачає.
Штат недоукомплектований на 500 робітників.
Згідно з нормативами в кожному зі скверів
мали б працювати, як мінімум,
вдвічі більше людей.
У районі вісім бригад.
Нам потрібні ще люди, які хочуть працювати.
В нас робота вважається важкою.
Але будь-яка робота, якщо її полюбити,
стає не такою вже й важкою.
Ось, зараз цей вірус.
Багато людей сидять вдома,
а ми працюємо й отримуємо зарплату.
"Київзеленбуд" міг би прямо зараз
взяти на роботу
не менше п’ятисот працівників-озеленювачів,
прибиральників, лісників
і тих, хто вміє вправлятися, приміром,
з бензопилами.
Проте бажаючих працевлаштуватися
на вільні вакансії немає.
Навіть на тлі безробіття, яке виникло
внаслідок закриття на карантин більшості підприємств.
За різними даними, влітку в Україні може з’явитися
понад три мільйони безробітних.
Це робітники, яких вже звільнили та звільнять
після виходу з неоплачуваної відпустки
та плюс заробітчани, що повернулися з-за кордону.
Уряд пропонує цим українцям тимчасові
заробітки на посткарантинний період.
Прем’єр Денис Шмигаль оголосив про створення
вже у травні півмільйона нових робочих місць.
Приблизно 120 тисяч з них
можуть бути створені на підприємствах
житлово-комунального господарства.
І тут нові робітники конче потрібні.
Лише в Києві вільних вакансій,
за даними КМДА,
від 10 до 12 тисяч.
У "Зеленбуді" готові навіть взяти і 800,
і тисячу нових робітників.
Але поки не очікують черг
перед своїми дверима.
Адже за урядовою програмою виходу з кризи
після карантину для нових працівників
передбачається зарплата
від 6 до 8 тисяч гривень
Об’єктивно, черги я не очікую.
Якщо ми говоримо про ініціативу уряду
в 6 тисяч гривень
для працівника, який працював в тій самій
Польщі чи ФРН, і заробляв по тисячі євро,
то, звичайно, це великий дисонанс,
на який він не піде.
Йому краще піти додому, отримувати
4200 гривень допомоги по безробіттю,
наприклад, і не йти на 6000 працювати.
Але він забуває про низку таких речей,
як соціальні гарантії,
пенсійний фонд, чесне і відкрите працевлаштування.
Озеленювач Михайло Ливаренко працює в "Зеленбуді" вже два роки.
Його задовольняє зарплатня -
тут середня складає 10 тисяч гривень
і соціальний пакет навіть з можливістю
літнього відпочинку в Херсонській області.
Він згоден, що шість або вісім тисяч гривень,
можливо, і маленькі гроші,
але точно не для всіх.
Принаймні, не для мешканців маленьких
населених пунктів навколо Києва.
Думаю, люди до нас прийдуть.
8 тисяч гривень - це як подивитися.
Для Києва - це мінімальна зарплата.
А якщо десь по селах взяти,
то це можуть бути гідні гроші.
Жити на такі гроші - майже неможливо,
погоджуються більшість опитаних DW киян.
Люди критикують ініціативу уряду.
Створюють армію рабів, які будуть працювати
за тарілку супу.
Молодь за 8 тисяч не хоче працювати.
А ті, що після 50-ти років будуть і за 8 тисяч…
Чим сидіти голодному, я так думаю.
Люди так збідніли, що
підуть працювати на таку суму.
Якийсь вихід з ситуації потрібно шукати.
В будь-якому випадку це непогано.
Враховуючи те, що люди вже три місяці вдома сидять,
виходити з кризи за 8 тисяч гривень на місяць
їм доведеться півроку.
Добре, що будуть робочі місця,
але треба хоча б 12 тисяч гривень,
аби на ноги якось встати.
З березня, за даними Держслужби зайнятості,
офіційно на біржі праці зареєструвалися
приблизно 120 тисяч українців.
Їм пропонується наразі вдвічі менше -
64 тисячі вакансій.
Більшість з них - робочі спеціальності.
59% пропозицій від роботодавців -
робота із зарплатою від 6 до 8  тисяч гривень.
Урядова ініціатива на цьому тлі
виглядає не такою вже й непривабливою.
За словами експертки з питань державного управління Юлії Алексєєвої,
держава навряд чи зможе платити зараз більше.
Хоча може розширити перелік галузей під нову ініціативу
зі створення робочих місць.
Адже актуальний наразі рівень безробіття - 13-15%.
І це найвищий показник за останні 15 років.
Держава може сформувати
певне державне замовлення на працю людей.
Вони можуть робити прості роботи на вулиці:
прибирати парки, збирати поліетилен, сміття уздовж доріг.
Щось можуть прямо вдома, наприклад,
щось шити можуть жінки на замовлення держави
для армії, медичних установ.
Робітниця "Київзеленбуду" Людмила Гамаюнова не приховує,
що дуже переймається за родини,
які втратили заробітки.
Вона згадує часи, коли вона виїхала
через війну з Луганська до Києва
і вимушена була деякий час жити
і без роботи, і без грошей.
Жінка не хоче, щоб те саме пережили інші родини
вже влітку, коли очікується пік безробіття.
Хто хоче працювати, роботу знайде.
Людмила сподівається, що уряд зможе
правильно розподілити бюджетні гроші
та інвестуватиме обіцяні
перші 4 мільярди гривень
у створення посткарантинних нових робочих місць
задля уникнення соціальної напруги.
Знайти тимчасову роботу за 6-8 тисяч гривень
українці зможуть не лише у ЖКГ.
Приміром, в соціальній галузі - допомагати соцробітникам
доглядати за літними людьми.
Ще на будівництві.
Уряд хоче створити тут
майже 170 тисяч робочих місць.
Планується, що цього року стартує програма
під назвою "Велике будівництво".
Команда Зеленського хоче побудувати
4 тисячі кілометрів доріг
і звести майже 300 об’єктів -
школи, дитсадки та лікарні.
Хоча прибутки держбюджету
вже скоротилися на 11%,
уряд обіцяє перерозподілити  фінанси,
аби мати гарантоване фінансування на оплату праці.